when i was in college three times
i tried stripping mail stripping what
did
you gain a lot of momentum in my book
three times
three times the first time was enough
for me
well after the first time you didn't
learn what happened the first time well
the first time hold on
did you go to strip club to audition uh
there was a guy
that i had met who listen i had i grew
up with no money
and i was working times are tough i was
working in the bowling alley at the
school
not making money not making money also
not a real
uh not a job that has a lot of respect
behind it no
not a lot of women are like oh you work
in the bowling alley at the school can
you give me a size seven yeah yeah it's
not we're not
so i was like what am i gonna do i wanna
make a little money maybe meet some
women
first of all i had no idea how women
act in those places it's so much more
insane than
oh it's like piranhas when you drop
chicken so much more but like
i have these skinny little legs they
don't care
but they were like super skinny they i
was getting manhandled
like they were they were like they're
going to want to hold oh you actually
did the damn thing
oh yeah i thought you auditioned for
like audition bruno i talked to this
dude and he was like yeah man come up he
was like can you dance i'm like i'm all
right
he goes all you got to do is just kind
of swing your dick around
and i was like okay what did you wear
well he
what his thing was he was like you got
to pick out your outfit and your song
oh oh so song what song dude there's so
many good ones but this is the 90s bro
you know yeah would you come out molly
crew man what song
come on doctor feel good i was coming
man
yeah i had to sit down on the third
second like just give me a second
but um is it packed with girls
it was packed i he was like how do you
feel about them holding you and i was
like what do you mean
and he was like well you're going to be
smaller than everybody and some of those
women are going to want to hug you or
hold you
yes it's not like tens are there you
know
it's like it's women that could hold me
oh dude it's
it's tlc 610 600 pound life who are
super
thirsty now yes and that's listen at
that time
i'm i'm still in pretty decent shape but
the time i'm walking around
four percent body fat probably well they
loved it oh they loved some josh
come on the wolf man coming out come on
dude so you hit that stage and did you
have nerves in the back
ah well i took a hit of ecstasy oh oh
yeah because i was like he was like you
might need this your first step and i
was like cool
sounds like a nice guy for what you're
dealing with
like at least he was like dude he was
grooming me yeah he's grooming you yeah
so did you have to get the the the dick
kind of fired up
no the i did you have to rev the engine
just a tad
i i i enhanced meaning well here's the
thing
i because he was like some guys kind of
jerk off a little bit
but then you know it goes away yeah
especially when you're on stage like
when you're on stage or you're about to
fight or do something athletic my dick
goes
retreat yeah they go in like a turtle so
i go what can i do to help it
and he said you know there are some
things that you can put around it
i guess the best thing is kind of like a
fleshlight but just for the shaft
it just makes it look girthier because
you're not taking your dick
again i like this guy yeah yeah yeah
everything you're saying makes a lot of
sense but what he didn't tell me
was that you're going to get lightheaded
a great but you're going to get a
it's they're going to be aggressive the
women it's a frenzy it's a great it's
shark week it's aggressive
it's a shark and so the first that's why
when i went back
and i told them so glad i'm taking an
ecstasy because i like people touching
me
but they'll they'll get in it they'll
get in it fingers did you so cody
oh i'm dude by the way i'm sure this
happens to you
meet and greets you telling me nobody
grabs your ass or your dick i get
sexually assaulted every meet and greet
me too i just take it i mean i'm just
like whatever dude they grabbed my ass
like me too ev every time and it's
usually in front of their husband i'm
like
definitely not comfortable with this i'm
not going to terry crews it and
write an article but but i'm with the
same that the dude it's not comfortable
the dude
the guy didn't give a [ __ ] here's the
thing it's usually a woman who's like
i'm not letting him in the picture
yes she's like no you take the picture
yeah she goes no he's gonna take the
picture like
well why don't you both just take it and
i'm like here we go yep and i know i'm
gonna get and i take it yeah
yeah i shut up and i take it you know
what i told one guy once
because his wife grabbed me by the ass
but the middle finger
went standard went to straight [ __ ]
the standard
and i told him i go hey man smell that
finger later
hey i've done three shows and i ate
about six pounds
of [ __ ] sweet and sour chicken from
yuck yuck yeah
smell that finger yeah you're gonna
wanna wait for that dude so your first
one you get manhandled bruises
tough no scratches no bruises scratches
scratches
and you came back well did you make good
money that was it
so he he was like this is your first
time out you don't get full dough
you want to come back next time we'll
give you full dough and he's a
businessman
he's a businessman he wanted to i went
back for phil doman
but i was like i need to be [ __ ] up
again the third time i did it
i'm like you know what i'm not gonna be
[ __ ] up and i just couldn't do it and
i was like if i
need something this is [ __ ] up i can't
make i can't do this it's gonna go down
a dangerous run
yeah man because you just you're
basically rick from rick and morty
hammered
all the time all the time dancing and i
didn't want to do that because i saw
some of those
older dudes who were like yeah man oh
and an
old scallywag at this [ __ ] male strip
club
you know super tan they look like did
you ever run all the trt
just [ __ ] died there they all looked
like a
shelter wrestler brutus the barber
beefcake yeah they smelled
beef cake pepper barber the beefcake was
that yeah you're right
super tan oh did you oh what was your
name oh
but tay i went joss
j-o-s-s they were like you're small make
your name a little more feminine
oh interesting and i was like so you're
not that small dude
compared to really were there some
beefcakes you gotta figure they were all
thunder down under those boys
have you been there they're beefy dudes
i have not they're beefy
and they've thundered out another beat
and they put on a hell of a show yeah
man
it's a show i was not putting on as much
of this show
i can't imagine i wasn't doing a carton
dance either you know what i'm saying
but i'm trying i was trying to be
schmexy man it's hard to be sexy with
motley crew playing that's why i had no
it's not bite your tongue
really oh my god i feel like i'd want to
come out like some juice what do you
want
to do it's like some genuine pick
yourself pick yourself oh dude there's
so many
song that you would call it dude i feel
like the motley crew
tip drill ti oh
i'll have to go pretty urban with it ah
man i wanted it to be a little wayne
really oh because you're lollipop little
wayne you're going slow you're
like this boy gay yeah
because that's the thing like those
thunder down under dudes most of them
are gay
they gotta put on an act that they're
seducing women most of those guys are
most those dudes like the way the dick
tastes
oh yeah is that true pretty sure dude
how do you know that to be that's the
rumor i might be
off yeah i'm pretty sure though dude
why because i will tell you and i'll
tell you off air
we have a comedian friend female
we were doing a show together at a at a
uh
resort at a casino and the show that was
playing in the theater next to us
was some australian strippers
and our comedian friend got down oh yeah
definitely tasted the australian
up down under dick now a bunch of down
under
just at one time just that one we were
just there for that night oh
so she but it was yeah and definitely
not gay
he went right up well not not all of
them i'm saying the majority how
it seems like you wouldn't i made that
up it seems like yeah it seems like you
would want
but it's like being a gynecologist too
like i wouldn't want the job
no i don't i wouldn't want the strip job
either because other than other boys are
yeah that come on dude that guy in the
front that kind of [ __ ] which one
which one that's gonna mean which one
again the front how come how come three
of them look like a different version of
ryan seacrest
what the look at the guy on the far left
which guy
okay that looks like my crowd at addison
emperor
i was gonna say this looks like your
mean green line
it really does toss on a couple tap out
shirts and that's a meet and greet for
brendan
which guy do you think out of this
is like oh this dude is the best thunder
down under i'd say they have the long
hair and the tats
i agree i think he doesn't really want
to be there you know but he's [ __ ]
good at it he can do the head shake his
head his long hair is wet
it chose him you know it chose him yeah
yeah i mean
how can you look like that and not find
your way
but how come what a career i can't
believe you did that dude the balls
why do i have better abs than two of
those guys more than two
it was i gotta tell you man i here's the
person that i am
i'm not gonna tell you i don't like
something if i've never done it that's
fair
and i love making myself uncomfortable
there are a couple things that i'm not
sure uh but they're i like making myself
uncomfortable
i like trying things that are going to
make a good story
i like doing things in your marriage i
don't know how much you want to get into
that but are you
that freaky with your marriage let's
just say i've pushed the envelope as far
as she wants to go
[Applause]
when i get off stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what just run a bunch of other comics
i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son